okay no my friend
it is hmm it's five o'clock on a
Thursday afternoon which means it's the
perfect time to embark on a completely
unnecessary journey are there a million
more things I should be doing right now
yes did I impulsively have an idea that
I cannot shake and will now invest my
time in that currently rather than the
million other things I should be doing
you damn right so I like to lovingly
refer to myself as a well-intentioned
mess which i think is fairly accurate
however my office space it's truly a
well-intentioned mess I've been talking
with my dear sweet wonderful friend my
college roommate and my first roommate
when I moved to New York after college
Michelle again we have kind of like
challenged not challenged to start
holding each other accountable because
both of us have messy offices we want to
fix them up and so it's a beautiful day
I just went for a run I'm feeling
irresponsibly invincible so I have a
thought that I could do a quick makeover
on my office space in like three hours
if I really put my mind to it by going
to Target and then coming back and
making changes I know that this is going
to end up bad but ignorance is bliss and
blissful ignorance is my favorite mode
to operate it it'll be fun and the thing
is none of the negative results effect
you are a personal level only me Oh
could you not like this video oh by the
way my name is GRU something but no no
you know your life is different now this
is not a sponsored video if it was
that'd be so great use me madam target
mayhaps you take interest in this rising
engaging youtube channel okay here's the
before I got 99 problems I got 99
problems I got 99 problems but I got 99
problems I got 99 problems this wall has
seen better days
I've hung many a thing on this wall and
spackled it and never repainted it and
now this thing is there because that's
not how a psychopath decorates their
office at all whatsoever so I'm thinking
maybe some like stick on wallpaper for
that hmm at one point I painted this
wall blue kind of in the same sort of
Bain an emotional stage that I'm feeling
right now like an attempt to like
add design to this room and it turns out
if you paint the wall blue the rest of
the room doesn't design itself lesson
learned I don't work in this space
because it makes me not feel good and
it's become just a collection zone look
I'm doing this in three hours ish four
hours ish so I don't have full
expectations that I'm gonna get it to a
point that it's gonna be perfect but at
least we could vastly improve on it
leave a comment down below how you think
this is gonna go well indented mess
I didn't wanna look for a run some
wallpaper tchotchkes and some
self-awareness over what I can't
accomplish and cannot we'll see if we
find a target okay let's recap do have a
game plan
no do I have the patience to make this
video over the course of several days
and actually go to multiple stores and
find things that I truly want for a long
term experience no I also just had to
get on my house that's not at all why
I'm doing this I just want to go to
Target and look at what Joanna Gaines is
got going on turns out having a game
plan might have been a better plan I
guess I look at rugs everything is cute
but everything is a blur do I need to
read 20 of those 20 of those maybe baby
yep slim pickins I don't know if I
actually like any of these this is
already going awry oh boy alright I'll
be honest that did not go as well as I
thought it would
I've made some design changes as if I
had a plan to begin with we'll see what
happens
I'm feeling less confident than the
moderate amount of confidence they had
before also I just saw on Instagram that
Lilly Singh just announced that she's
gonna have an NBC late-night talk show
she credible meanwhile I'm buying a
photo of a cow
times have changed okay we're back with
our couch your mouse I don't think is
gonna be a massive J Pigpen pick Gooden
to be full-on farm because I guess
that's my aesthetic now so I said I
wanted to put like a wallpaper or
temporal paper over there but it's funny
that I liked so I got this like peachy
blush color paint I think I might paint
like a giant accent square and then a
rug and see if we can trim and move
things around you often need a little
fast-forward and you can see how this
goes see how she blows see how this is
going to blow it's combo and on the way
and that people usually like
[Music]
pure beauty subtract 48 not questioning
everything I'm changing plans I'm saying
yes if it's just stress mating
okay
I bought this what looks pink but I
think it's peach but it might be not who
knows color that I'm gonna use as an
accent color on this wall this is a
remix I know how to do it I love the
easiest routes and not my favorite shoes
oh I just kicked the cow
oh you don't that euphemism see what
color this looks like it's like if
someone threw up into a bottle of Pepto
Bismol cute let's see I usually hate
pink why are you doing this oh it's
everywhere
oh it's pepto-bismol it's everywhere
it's barely making a difference cute
okay we'll do a couple coats
our first coated sound is made little to
no difference okay cool p.m. Ellen bet
great choice is all around topic oh it's
just in pain mother I'm not redecorating
is boring hours and layers later square
33 private honestly I'm really proud of
this I haven't put the thing up yeah a
little bit as Joanna Gaines would say
let's whip it
I'm really sorry to report but this is
cute as heck ah need that super super so
I can just my shoulders up oh my god I
just got excited that cow so mad and
it's got bangs makes me so happy
you know I'm going to test some things
and move some stuff around and you'll
see it in fast motion
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now / finishing consciousness uh
oops it's the next day no I did a bunch
of work on the room I'm kind of happy
with it I don't think it's done so I did
not meet my goal of getting it done in
the time I allotted myself but that's
okay because target didn't meet my goal
and it provided me everything I didn't
know I absolutely needed to finish the
room so it evens out okay qhq ish I
don't know if I like that and then
there's all this still so we made some
progress oh hi that doesn't work this
kind of works but it also will fully
slice your fingers off so no no just
decoration is candle rules it's called
leather oak from Target I love it glad I
put a mirror up on this wall hi I
covered this with a pillowcase because
I'm domestically DIY innovative as Jaime
and then here's some of this stuff this
will make it a de - I don't know how I'm
feeling about any of this right now
my mom made this rock and I got it in a
white elephant during Christmas one time
uh-huh and then this I don't I don't
know what's happening here where it's a
good start I feel like I've accomplished
something while avoiding accomplishing
some of the things I should be doing and
wanting to accomplish I hope you guys
enjoyed this little journey together let
me know what you thinking if you have
any suggestions on ways I could either
figure out the corner situation I don't
know if you like any hope you like
domesticating grace - grace vacated
domestic grace domestic in Grace's I had
a stroke it was freestyle don't forget
to subscribe to this YouTube channel I
put videos up and then that I don't know
this one clearly did not just come back
from a w it me